Technology businesses are like sharks, too.
You either move forward ambitiously or poof!
You become either small or irrelevant or both.
I don't want either of those for Microsoft.
My greatest joy in the long run for Microsoft...
...well, to see it achieve even greater heights in the next five or ten years.
I'm probably the biggest shareholder in Microsoft today.
So what's my greatest wish?
That Microsoft change in the way that keeps it successful.
I think it is hard for technology companies to be successful if they are not ambitious.
So the one thing I talk to everybody who we were considering to replace me...
...is how ambitious they were for Microsoft.
We had discussions with Facebook about buying Facebook.
But Zuckerberg knew what he viewed as an outcome.
That he really desired and was willing to put in the blood sweat and tears just like we were.
So execution and measurement...
...are hugely important yet people let themselves off the hook.